alors est ce que jean louis murat vous
êtes prêts pour une interview jugement
dernier
[Applaudissements]
jean louis murat
c'est le jugement dernier mais j'en ai
eu ras vous pensé à la mort une
demi-heure par jour
ah bon donc vous êtes prêts pour
l'interview jugement dernier
jean louis murat quand tu étais petit
as tu essayé de regarder sous le bureau
de ta maîtresse
jamais
il était plein
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets jamais il
était en plein air
jean louis durand
as-tu jouer au docteur avec tes copains
jamais il n'était jamais malade c'est
bien merci
jean louis murat avec ce professeur
d'anglais qui t'a fait lire coridon es
tu sûr qu'il ne sais vraiment rien passé
sexuellement tu es bien bien sûr que non
jean louis murat
as-tu utiliser ta notoriété pour obtenir
des avantages particuliers
des fois les bonnes places au resto tout
ça absorbe tue encore des substances
illicites jamais
jamais il est tué je suis humain
justement c'est bien qu'on soit on tente
purgatoire éventuel m'est étranger
est il arrivé d'avoir envie de la femme
d'un autre
jamais gêné principe
est il arrivé de trompeta femmes jamais
gêné principe est il arrivé de trompeta
maîtresse
c'est jamais une maîtresse
jean louis murat as tu ne serait ce
qu'une fois
emmerder le monde par plaisir
jamais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu